as promised into the second half of this
and I'm gonna again run through some
examples from the back half of the
exercise but before I do that I actually
want to revisit 6f as promised and I
know some of you know II wrote a comment
here have anticipated this but when you
have a look at this integral to X plus 1
all squared with respect to X if you
weren't given any instructions then you
might not have thought oh I should
expand this integrand like I showed you
up there in green there there's another
way to do this and I would argue it
actually is more efficient business
working out that you need to worry about
and that's with reverse chain rule
it's like chain rule because we're not
differentiating but we're undoing that
process so that's why we call it reverse
chain rule let me show you how it works
when you take this integral instead of
expanding we can notice that it's sort
of in the form F dash times F to some
power almost that is you've got this if
we call this guy in here let's label
this f of X okay and it's being raised
to the power of two the F dash X that
would come from chain rule you know
you're inside derivative in this case it
would just be a number two so there
would be a constant coefficient that
will be added if we differentiate it and
got to this result now constant
coefficients can be multiplied or
divided by and they don't dramatically
change what's happening with with the
calculus I can show you how to use that
fact to do this integral what we're
going to do is very similar to how we
did it before I'm going to increase the
index divided by that new index and we
just add one more step in because of
that reverse chain rule so let's have a
go for starters I'll have that 2x plus 1
that was there before increase the index
up to 3 divided by that new index so
I've got the 3 there at this point what
am I dealt with I've dealt with the
outside of this function it was a thing
raised to a power now I have to deal
with the inside which is 2x plus 1 I've
got a divided by that derivative as well
which is times 2 so this part here is
the inside derivative and
is the outside so at this point I've
completed reverse chain rule and I add
my constant so this is it I can tidy
that up a teeny little bit I'll write a
sixth 2x plus 1 or cubed plus my
constant and it's very easy to verify
that this is the correct integral or the
correct indefinite integral by actually
differentiating this guy you can see
that 3 will come out the front I'll
reduce the index by 1 becomes 2 and the
2 from the inside derivative comes out
the front completely canceling the 1
over 6 which leads us back to the
integral that we started with all 1 that
we wanted to integrate so that's how you
can check that and now we're going to
use this reverse chain rule again with
these other tougher questions so go over
the page in your textbook to 13f and I'm
just gonna put a little wave a little
red flag here 13f in the textbook it
says by using the formula and then they
give you sort of this monstrosity here
of if you're integrating something in
this exact form ax plus B to the power
of n with respect to X and then you get
all this this garbled mess on the right
hand side now there's nothing wrong with
the formula it's correct but for me I
actually think for most people it will
be counterproductive to like memorize
that formula and then use it
mechanically every time you encounter a
question like this reason number one is
that you're going to encounter plenty of
questions that are not exactly like this
form and so you're going to be using a
lot of mental space to memorize this
it's not an easy or intuitive formula to
memorize and secondly if you're
memorizing a very prescriptive set of
steps then as soon as you have something
which is adjusted to that you're going
to think oh do I do I use this or do I
not and then it becomes a question of
when the formula replies and when it
doesn't I'd much prefer you to be
understanding the way the chain rule
works when you differentiate and then
being able to say okay I can apply that
in Reverse so let's have a go at 13f it
says there I'm going to integrate 8 over
4 X plus 1 to the power of 5 with
respect to X ok so here's the way I'm
going to approach this there are two key
things that I'm going to do before I
integrate
set it up for integration and this goes
back to mrs. Liza's point before the
simplification that I do isn't the
integrating the integrate their setting
up I'm about to do is to sort of make it
ready for integrating it's a little bit
like you know all of the if you're
cooking a meal right there's all of the
chopping and peeling and probably
peeling and then chopping you do all of
that first before you even turn the heat
on and get cooking so I'm not going to
turn the heat on yet I'm just going to
prepare the ingredients as it were to
carry the metaphor I'll stop carrying
the metaphor it's just confusing now so
first things first
that ate that you can see there on the
numerator I'm actually going to write at
the front of the integral that eight
might be useful for me later I might
cancel with some things but for now I
just don't really want to have to think
about more numbers than I need to so
I'll move that eight out of the way what
am i integrating will rather than write
this in fractional form as you saw
before it's much easier to deal with
this if we write it with a negative
index so in this case I would write that
as 4x plus 1 to the power of negative
five and then I'm going to do it with
respect to X so my ingredients already
sorry the metaphor came back I couldn't
help it I'm breeding to go now I'm
actually going to do the integration so
that 8 was outside of the integral so
I'm just gonna write that down that's x
well what will my result be okay let's
have a look here I've got 4x plus 1 and
first I'm going to deal with the outside
something to the power of negative 5 I
will increase the integral which gives
me negative 4 and then I'm going to
divide by that new index so now I've
dealt with the outside what's left well
I've got to deal with the inside as well
4x plus 1 what is the derivative that
you have there it's going to be 4 right
so I've dealt with the outside now I've
dealt with the inside and then I add C
because this is an indefinite integral
so the integration is done and I should
tidy this up because it is a bit of a
garbled mess I've got an 8 on the top
and then I've got 16 on the bottom it
looks like so I can do some canceling
immediately there's a factor of 8 that I
can cancel so that would become 1 and
and if that's 16 down the bottom then it
leaves me with a factor of two you've
also got excuse me a negative on the
bottom but I think it's easier to write
that on the top so I'm gonna write a
negative one on the top and then on the
denominator I'm gonna have that to that
you could see I wrote in red excuse me
again sorry about that
and then I've also got this 4x plus 1
term which as mrs. Lee's pointed out I
think she typed it in the chat window
it's nice to provide back your answer in
the form that the question gave it to
you in the question didn't have any
negative indices I put the negative
indices in there to make it easier to
deal with so I'm going to return it to
positive indices which means this 4x
plus 1 raised to a power it's going to
go on to the denominator it's a 4 and
then I say plus C and now I'm finished
I'm looking over it looks like it's as
simple as it needs to be so you can deal
with that
that 8 by taking out the front and then
do reverse chain rule just like we did
on our question 6 okay